hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah i'm just checking in on you
checking in to see how you're doing
what's up sports fans
fans of many sports what are you guys
doing what are you watching watching the
nba watching the end uh the [__] nhl
are you watching major league baseball
i'm just excited that it's back i'm not
excited that that [__] air
conditioner just cranked
right in the beginning of this um
whatever it's better than
sitting outside in the [__] heat [__]
with all them mosquitoes
um joe rogan just [__] instagram
something terrifying
something about a bunch of genetically
altered mosquitoes
now in theory it seems like it's going
to work
that these [__] mosquitoes go out and
they breed with these genetically
i think are they sterile
is it cheryl are they sterile sterile
cheryl
i have a friend named cheryl and she's
got plenty of babies why would you
introduce that it's bad enough that
white women just lost the name
karen now you're going to try to take
away cheryl
what next nancy
um genetically altered
mosquitoes what's the end game everybody
i swear to god
you guys remember that show breaking bad
of course you do
all right spoiler alert no
remember everything walter white did to
fix a problem just created another
problem
750 million genetically engineered
mosquitoes approved
all right what is the purpose of this
and why weren't we allowed this is one
of these things like why aren't we
allowed to vote on this
hey man like we're gonna just start
making genetically altered mosquitoes
ah jesus christ i'm in the middle of
nowhere right now my first road gig in a
long time and i got i got country i got
that country ass
internet what's your what's your rush
city boy we got a whole [__] day out
here
you know jesus didn't have internet
um look what he accomplished
all right cnn oh jesus they're gonna
somehow blame trump for this
um and i'll go on fox news and they're
gonna say uh
it was [__] obama's no clinton
hillary clinton's fault
they came out of her vagina uh a plan to
release over 750 million genetically
modified mosquitoes
skaters into the florida keys in 2021
and 2022. this is
people in florida you realize you [__]
up so many times on national news that
you are now
expendable all right you don't see them
doing this in georgia
do you ain't [__] with them georgia
peaches
um receive the final approval from local
authorities against the objections of
many local residents
and coal and a coalition
coalition sorry of environmental
advocacy groups the proposal has already
won
state and federal approval with the
urgent crisis facing our nation
and the state of florida the covid 19
pandemic
racial injustice climate change jesus
christ can they put enough stuff on this
sandwich
um jalapeno peppers the space race the
cold war
fascism the administration has used tax
dollars and government resources
for a jurassic park experiment
now wait a minute are you supposed to do
the experiment before you do this
should jd hanson policy director of
above
now the monroe county mosquito control
district has given the final permission
needed
what could what could possibly go wrong
we don't know because epa unlawfully
refused to seriously analyze
environmental risks now without further
a view of the risk the environment the
experiment can proceed
what are they trying to achieve approved
by the environment
the pilot project is designed to test if
a genetically modified mosquito
scale is a viable alternative to
spraying insecticides
to control
the aedes edge i guess that's
what is that latin for mosquito it's a
species of mosquito that
carries several deadly diseases such as
zika
dengue and chukaganya
and yellow fever yellow fever heard of
those other three need to get a
publicist
all right this is what the [__]
problem is is nature is trying
to get us back in balance
you know with these diseases and that's
what the mosquitoes are for and now
we're going to stop it so let's say this
[__] works
the population is going to continue to
grow wildly out of control and create
more problems
all right so what i blame is
religion and god for this i blame both
i blame them both
all right i blame religion because
religion
says god creates created us in his
image and he thinks we're the greatest
especially if you're part of my religion
as all religions say and then i blame
god
for being dumb enough for to create
human beings that would do [__] like
this
or maybe he did it because he wanted to
watch what have i created an animal that
thinks they can actually beat nature
what would that look like you know i've
been
laying her what the hell has he been
doing he's been laying around since he
created the [__] universe
i don't know sometimes i really believe
it's just a kid playing with his toys
you ever hear that theory
eventually he's gonna get too old to
play what the [__] was that noise that
was unsettling
[__] door closing um anyway so there
you go genetically altered mosquitoes
and they sent them right down to [__]
florida and you know what you dumb [__]
you deserve it
you deserve it you know mask wearing
[__] morons you know i was thinking
about this [__] the other day the fact
that people
like [__] idiots with my level of
education a questioning scientist you
know i saw something all day
they [__] these guys figured out how
to make like a micro pancreas
okay to cure diet and they say that's
going to cure diabetes
which means they figured out how to give
a rat diabetes
they're growing ears on the back of rats
okay i mean what the [__] can you do huh
steal cable if they tell you to wear a
[__] mask you idiots
i i'm on the facebook everybody because
i'm an old person and i
love i absolutely love that we drove
all of us old people drove all the young
people away from facebook i love that it
was your club and then we all showed up
and your fun ended
i enjoyed that that's one of the great
things about being old
you know at first i was fighting and i
was like no i want to do that i want to
walk into where they're
you know longest time i've been i don't
want to do that i want to do it on
social media
oh god mom can't i post without you
being on my
site that shit's just funny to me um
anyway uh let's talk a little bit of
playoff hockey
did i call it or did i call it with the
st
louis blues series i did
until last night i was watching the game
the other day when i did my podcast
on a sunday evening and the vancouver
canucks
were up two games to none against the
saint louis
black and blues right
the blues as joe barton from puck off
calls him
which is hilarious he still calls him
that they're defending stanley cup
champions right and
i i said you know they need to win game
three
because you know i watched my bruins go
up two or against them and then they
just beat us down to their [__]
talent level
and won the game and you know what
the canucks loss game was at game three
and then they lost game four it was tied
to
two and then the blues went up three
games to one and you know what i was
saying to myself
i was like bill it's time for you to
stop being a [__] baby about your
[__] stupid team losing last year the
blues won fair and square
stop crying about it and i was all ready
to do that and then the canucks came
back
scored two unanswered to tie it up in
regulation to go into overtime
and then they had the game winner to win
four to three i missed the whole game
because i was out last night doing
stand-up which is such a fun thing to
say
i miss my boston bruins coming back in
the third period
on monday night i missed him closing it
out last
night because i was doing stand-up
bruins be caroline four games to one
vegas closes out chicago four games to
one vancouver canucks
three games to two i i finally now
respect the the uh st louis blues
like they give a [__] but um i have a
pitch
for my boston bruins you know what i
mean for when we come back
and all is well and you know they always
have like songs
you know you know like whenever there's
a fight on the ice they play like why
can't we
be friends why can't we be friends they
they do that type of [__] you know they
play old rock songs
i got one for david crady
whenever he scores a goal do you
remember that guns and roses song
second side appetite for this uh
destruction you're crazy
you're [__] crazy banana
i think they should play the end right
that bring it down you're [__] crazy
whenever he scores you know and if there
weren't [__] kids there
they could do it come on you know you
are bring it down your [__] crazy
sorry [__] throw this dry [__] out
here
or maybe i don't know how to sing
properly wouldn't that be a great one
what does this say to the children stop
saying the f word while they watch
adults beat the [__] out of each other
well they learn how to change the tone
they don't like to tone in their
classroom
drop the gloves what else has happened
um i love the call last night by jack
edwards
when i watched the highlights when the
bruins uh patrice bergeron
they tied it up one to one there was
like [__] three and a half seconds
left
and um there was a shot on net
uh there was a save by marazzic
it goes behind the neck bergeron goes to
get it as he's going to get it he's
glancing over his shoulders see what his
options are out front
sees there isn't any he spins around he
looks out front like he's going to pass
it to someone and just
threw it into the legs of the goalie
wreck his shade off and went into the
net
and um jack edwards just go
murat he caught my razzy and he goes
marasic took a
nap
[Laughter]
gotta love a homer what's up sweetheart
what do you say to us we don't oh yeah
we got a new credit card cause somebody
double
swiped our [__] or did somebody misplace
you misplaced it i like your outfit you
look beautiful
oh yeah you're just gonna go strut
around town who is he
huh you banging a farmer um
all right you don't have to be
lonely at farmersonly.com
um colorado sends the coyotes packing
with an impressive 7-1
victory and look at the look at the
[__] montreal canadiens
the montreal canadiens up 3-2 over your
number one seed in the east
philadelphia flyers uh dallas up three
to two
islanders up 3-1 looking to close out
the caps today
dallas looking to close out the [__]
canucks and then over to the nba
what do we got speaking of philly losing
jesus christ the boston celtics
absolutely hammering the philadelphia
76ers last night
128 101 up two games to none but i'll
tell you a seven game series could turn
around quick
i'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
the 76ers gotta get back into this
series with the big victory in game
number three
um mavericks 127 114 why the [__] are
they playing the clippers
are they out in the west mavericks
i'll never i'll never you know milwaukee
brewers to me are still in the american
league
why the milk neil why are the milwaukee
bucks playing the la clippers
well you know at this time it really
seems like the franchises are looking to
try something different
that was really good um
on the mavericks i'm sorry i'm thinking
milwaukee bucks i'm a dope
sorry mavericks i just saw an m i really
should get my [__] brain checked out
all right bucks are playing the magic 6
p.m today with the greek
freak um running wild out there
in cream city there's still a team to
beat out in the east
i'd love to see the milwaukee bucks win
a championship wouldn't that be great
portland trailblazers who is that guy
out there reigning the [__] threes
down on the lakers
i don't watch a lot of nba but i do
follow crime faces
on uh on instagram and the dude who runs
that was going off on it
when you're done all right
yeah just text me whatever you just said
because you did such an exaggerated
thing i couldn't read your lips all i
was looking at was your teeth
um all right anyway so yeah i did
another spot less i've got three spots
this week
all right after it it um
going uh not fun saturday night
and then me figuring out how to play a
parking lot i was doing stand-up in the
woods last night
and uh popped in did a show in a field
and i had a great [__] time i
actually had a great time
i was saying stupid [__] and
uh as far as i know i didn't get in
trouble for it
so i'm gonna go out on a limb and i'm
gonna say stand up is back
um yeah i think it's back
so i'm going to uh i'm gonna try to
figure out i'm gonna start doing some
shows
probably out east um the northeast
area is probably where i'm going to go
because uh who's kidding who i don't
know
you know i try i've tried to defend
the red states and you guys are just
you're just [__] blowing it
all right with you in it but actually
but i live in california we're also
blowing it
so i don't know i'm just [__] with
you i'm gonna go there because it seems
like that's the least amount of covid
because i don't want anybody
to catch covid going to the show or
whatever
and uh and all you know what freckles
needs to make a little bit of money i'm
not going to lie to you okay
you know you might have seen me on uh i
love the 80s strikes back
on vh1 okay but just cause i'm on that
doesn't mean i can't work for the rest
of my life okay
i'm not i'm not living like that i got a
mortgage too
all right i also got a [__] mosquito
is that one of them genetically once do
i let it bite me
huh why don't they make genetically
altered mosquitoes that don't have that
[__] thing we uh
well because they got to eat right
i don't know why are we [__] with
nature
here's a good one for you nature is
perfect
if you don't [__] with it it's perfect
human beings
are extremely flawed
you know well i guess animals are flawed
too you got the weak one in the litter
i have no idea all i know is that we
should not be going out here playing god
genetically altered mosquitoes well
guess what improv i won't be doing soon
the florida keys chuckle hut will not be
on my [__]
why don't they make so what do they have
down there do these genetically altered
ones
do they have like mosquito aids or
something like that and then these guys
these [__]
mosquitoes are gonna go raw in them and
then they're gonna die
is that what it is i don't know
everybody
that [__] you know you got to love a
fly though flies are great they eat [__]
you know what i mean they land on you
they're just annoying
flies are just annoying you know
everybody has that one person in their
group of friends that they just keep
hanging around even though they're
annoying but a mosquito
you got to cut that out of your life um
i will tell you what i am
liking that i had been watching i didn't
notice
until mike milbury brought it up he was
talking about the flip pass
as you're bringing it out of your zone
um
it's sort of like an over-the-shoulder
pass with the puck and these guys have
it down
and i'm thinking like all of these years
of doing the dump and chase
the flip pass seems to be
uh thwarting the lock the trap whatever
you want to call it
it's [__] amazing you know and all
the shooter has to do is settle the puck
down
i don't give a [__] i'm just so happy i
get to talk about sports
so anyways i am out here in the middle
of nowhere
uh where i wouldn't mind living i'll be
honest with you
um i've been out here since yesterday
we flew out here and you know what i do
now because i'm so back into uh
doing the helicopter [__] is um i would
love
to fly a helicopter out here um i'm out
here and
i can't see where i'm at but i'm out
here and uh
it's it's
what i just love when i was coming into
land was
all i could think of is if you had an
engine failure you have
so many places that you could put it you
know
but the great equalizer out here is the
weather i'm not used to flying in
weather
so but still i would just look at the
forecast and i i just would [__]
you know just fly on nice days
and then i could be over green grass
you know as opposed to just uh flying
over a city
trying to find a street where there's
not a bunch of people on it if you ever
had a problem so it's kind of cool and
um
i don't know i like this [__] i know
there's a bunch of comedians leaving la
but you know what i'm toughing it out
i'm hanging in there you know i love
l.a i don't give a [__] because i just
don't get
where where are you going to go that's
my thing
i understand leaving because you're
getting this [__] kicked out of you
in taxes i understand leaving because
you don't [__] like the place but
like
um i don't know it just seems like
everywhere you go there's going to be a
new set of problems you go to florida
they got genetically altered mosquitoes
all right you go you go to wyoming you
have people that were born in wyoming i
mean everywhere you go there's gonna be
a problem
kidding although i did go to wyoming i
went there one time to do a show
and i did not have a good show they were
looking at me like i had [__] 12
heads
it's always bugged me so i have to go
back and i'm gonna kill this [__] fly
right now
no not cause i'm gonna use my hand and
everybody know oh i got him i got him
you [__] dead [__]
i should start taking karate huh
although i didn't use chopsticks i used
my [__]
i used my hand
how [__] white was that movie jesus
christ i can't what do
asian people asian people who are in the
martial arts
world how insulting was that movie to
your [__] culture
that absolutely ridiculous fight stance
which i know a bunch of people have made
fun of but
let's just get on to the whole [__]
uh you know you whack some cars wax on
wax off
and then all of a sudden you know how to
block punches
am i really to believe that there's
white-haired old asian guys
in asia with chopsticks trying to
[__] catch mosquitoes and flies out
of the [__]
air ah jesus christ
i would say what do you think was more
offensive
to uh the art of martial the martial
arts
the karate kid or frank sinatra's
first white guy doing karate on on an
american cinema in the manchurian
candidate
remember that where he had one hand
doing the horizontal karate chop
[__] thing and then uh then he had
his fit he
had a balled up fist right behind it
like he was gonna do uh bruce lee's
one-inch punch
um i don't know that stuff all
fascinates me um
the the writers like i was talking about
the coming of age movies
how it's just oh it's always going to be
in the writer's voice so the jock
who's dating a beautiful cheerleader he
has to be a total dick he treats her
like [__] and then the [__] nerd is
actually you know
really interesting
[Laughter]
who do you think thinks more
about their about high school once they
leave
a nerd because nothing that they wanted
to have happened
happened or
the popular person this is an
interesting question or the popular
person like how i just deemed this an
interesting question because i'm asking
and i want to know the answer
or the popular person that [__]
you know was [__] crushing ass
was killing it on the on the gridiron or
whatever i mean can you imagine being
popular and good looking
in the in [__] high school and you go
into this high school every day
and every chick is available basically
it's like your night club
they all like you they don't all like
you but you know your ego's telling you
that
you got your pick of the [__] litter
they're not pressuring you to marry them
you don't have any [__] money so what
can you really buy
them it's perfect it's [__] perfect
and then you go out in the real world
and all your work 12 grades of being
this [__]
all goes out the [__] window and you
got to re-establish yourself
for the first time in your life nobody
knows who you are or gives a [__]
then you got to go to the next level and
you got to compete with all of those
other popular kids it's like making your
way up to sports ranks
rankings right
i wonder who thinks or you're the nerd
actually i was the cool person i know
how to make genetically altered
mosquitoes
why won't she touch my pee pee um
i don't know
by the way how great's a lock playing
for the bruins you know the man is
getting the job done
um anyway i gotta i gotta do a little
bit of advertising here i'm out here in
the middle of nowhere
i brought my entire family with me we're
having a great time
um as long as i stay out of everybody's
way you know as long as i stay out of
everybody's way everyone will have a
good time
this country ass [__] internet i
can't get my [__] emails to load
so hang on a sec ah jesus christ you
know you try to type in your password
and it just doesn't work
all right here we go we got we got a
couple of two reads here oh look who it
is
would you look who just walked in the
door talk about crushing ass
in high school it's simply safe
everybody
simply safe crushed ass in high school
always work condom
uh simply safe here's the thing about
home security companies
most trap you with high prices tricky
contracts and lousy customer support
so while there are a lot of options out
there there's only
one no-brainer simply safe in other
words
ladies you can go out there and go bang
a bunch of guys but there's only going
to be one guy
out there for you that's going to be a
great father
and put up with your [__] [__]
simply safe's got everything you need to
protect your home with none of the
drawbacks of traditional home security
it's got an arsenal of sensors and
cameras to blanket every room
window door tailored specifically for
your
home professional monitoring keeps watch
day and night
ready to send police fire or medical
professionals
if there's an emergency you can set it
up yourself in under an hour
just peel and stick the sensors exactly
where you need them no technician
required
and there's no contract no pushy sales
guy no hidden fees
no fine print all this starts at 15
a month i'm not the only one who thinks
simply safe is great
u.s news and world report named it the
best overall home security
of 2020. try simply save today and
simply save at simplysafeburr.com
you get uh free free shipping and a
60-day
risk free trial there's nothing to lose
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e-b-u-r-r
dot com uh or simply safe wait
is it simply safebro.com yeah that's it
simplysafebird.com
um by the way you know why these [__]
guys pick the florida keys
because it's right at the outskirts of
our country
you know what i mean it hangs off into
the [__] water so they're going down
there and it's not like these
genetically altered [__] mosquitoes
aren't gonna [__] make their way up
just like the killer bees did remember
the killer bees
killer bees came along and what happened
then what the [__] happened then
they didn't kill anybody i think that's
what happened that was a big that was
sort of the ishtar the insect world
um by the way where the [__] do you
house 750 million
[__] genetically altered mosquitoes
you know i wonder if they were they were
talking to them
you know as they stayed in this giant
like basketball [__] arena
at the perfect temperature
they're all [__] in there there's
some mad scientists just walking around
at the top of the [__] arena all
glassed in
you're better than the mosquitoes you're
going to encounter
you're going out there remember
always smile at the regular mosquitoes
romanticize them
i'm trying to think what the word is
seduce them
[__] them infect them with your
genetically altered mosquito penis
sorry all right legalzoom everybody as
an employer you've got a lot on your
plate running your business
ensuring workplace safety and much more
yeah you got a ton on your plate now
jesus christ
you know you got some whiny friggin
white chick working there god knows what
she's going to [__] about and all of a
sudden you don't have a job anymore
but wait i started this business we
don't want you anymore
so leave your hiring to the one place
that makes finding qualified candidates
fast and easy
ziprecruiter.com zip
recruiter uh dot com
why did this say legalzoom now all of a
sudden it's zip recruiter
is this genetically altered bill burr
trying to did i get bit by one of those
[__] things
zip recruit has sent your job to over
100 of the web
this is a zip recruiter read of the
web's leading job sites but they don't
stop there
with their powerful tech matching
technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right
experience and actively invites them to
apply
to your jobs
[Music]
makes the entire hiring process
efficient and effective with features
like screening questions to filter
candidates
and an all-in-one dashboard where you
can review your rates
and rate your candidates yeah screen
them have you ever been to the florida
keys since the genetically altered
mosquitoes got there
great why don't you get your little
[__] lunch box and get out of my
office
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day and right
now
to try uh to try ziprecruiter for free
my listeners can go to zip
[Music]
spell it out okay z i p
r e c r u i
t e r dot com slash bird zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
um jesus christ what the [__] are we
doing first we genetically alter their
food now we're going with mosquitoes
what are they going to make nest next a
a not ferocious lion
that's what they're going to do they're
going to start genetically altering
exotic animals
basically wild animals so they're going
to be like dogs
which really were genetically altered
right what did they do
they had to run to the litter of all the
wolves
they just had for for centuries
the biggest [__] [__] in the wolf
pack
the one that nature didn't want to breed
you know that's what they made human
beings are [__]
we are like amazing and out of our
[__] minds do you how the [__] do you
make
do you take a wolf and pick the wolf
that the thing's gonna [__] and then
somehow in the end you end up with one
of those lobstops
whatever the [__] you call them lobster
oopses
you know and then we have all these
different [__]
we breed all these dogs long snouts so
they can get in there and get that fox
out of the [__] hole and all of that
[__]
and now that everybody goes to the
grocery store to hunt now now they're
just coming up with ones that just
make women go oh
you know like cocker poodle or whatever
the [__] they hate what the [__] do they
have
uh um a
labradoodle like those things
exist for no reason other than to just
be cute
to make people go oh my god i'll spend
some money on that
so there was like scientists
just making dogs [__] you know
like that weird manager that managed
that that [__] group bow wow wow
oh my god he was trying to get caught
he was encouraging the band members to
all bang each other isn't that what
happened
how weird is that and they were named
after the noise that dogs don't really
make but we say they do
i think that's called the full circle of
life there so they sit there and they go
they just [__] like what do they do
they make sure the dog doesn't jerk off
they get them all horny and then they
bring in they're [__] their dogs how
many [__] that well that's your only
option dog's like ah jesus christ
gets over there and just bangs it and
then they see what it has
not quite cute enough they got to sit
there and look at other
how the [__] did they do scientists i
don't know
the worst thing about scientists is the
fact that they've now been brought into
the corporate fold
and how all the corporations care about
is
the bottom line and making money in all
of that [__]
so then they take these people talents
and they put them towards evil [__]
oh geez bill you're going deep now i
mean you just you just said a lot of
deep crazy [__] but you have not given
us one example
all right fair enough fair enough why
can't i say scary things on the internet
that's what everybody else is doing
aren't they
genetically altered [__] mosquitoes
you know you know what's funny is
they're not trying to save human beings
because they give a [__] about human
beings
all right they need you to be alive
okay so you can get into debt that you
can't quite get out of your entire life
so these people can continue i don't
understand why they don't just kill all
of us
you know except for some people that
know how to build [__]
you know why don't they just wipe
everybody out except for some top chefs
construction people scientists to keep
you alive i mean how many people would
you need
that's a good movie right there right
the top ten
thousand
now how many people do you think you to
know everything
that we know i mean and i'm saying it's
all written down
and you have access to with computers
and all that okay so you got to keep
you got to keep some geek squad people
for when your [__] laptop goes
why not i don't think you need them well
yeah you do
no you don't you this way you got to
take some people from [__]
that round building there near stanford
where all those [__]
nameless people create come up with
these amazing inventions
that dead steve jobs still keeps taking
credit for
from beyond the grave i wonder if he was
[__] genetically altered
there was something going on with that
guy where he wore the same anybody wears
the same [__] clothes every day
is either a douche or uh genetically
altered
you know what i mean stop trying to
align yourself with [__]
einstein all right he figured it out you
know
and now you're trying to do the same
thing i just have so much stuff to think
about today i can't take time
to pick out this t-shirt or that t-shirt
nobody's that [__] busy
you know i mean einstein
he did it back in the day when people
sewed together their own [__] clothes
no but there was there weren't nice
clothes back then actually wait a minute
that chanel chick was around wasn't she
the one who was sympathetic to the nazis
how come she doesn't get canceled
you [__] [__] you trying to
change the name of airport i know why
because she's got a vagina
you [__] stupid [__] all right
i am so happy to be back doing [__]
stand-up comedy
um and that's it that is that is that is
all she wrote you know um
sports are back it doesn't take a lot to
keep me going you know
a little breakfast sandwich here or
there i'm gonna go hang out with my
family
uh that's it
that is the podcast enjoy the music
picked out by the wonderful andrew
themeless
and then we're gonna have a bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
this episode will be from a couple of
years ago
it'll eat up another freaking hour of
your half hour your time and there you
go
then you only got 23 more hours to kill
if you're doing blow
all right the rest of you i don't know
what to tell you all right
other than uh have a great weekend you
[__] and i'll see you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 20th 2012. how's it going
how are you i can't [__] hear myself
i don't know what the [__] happened to
my uh my other my regular
my regular headphones which suck by the
way
because they flake all over my ears what
does that mean bill i don't know little
pieces of plastic
you know like they don't have the space
age
technology whenever somebody uses that
expression you know they have no idea
what they're talking this is just coming
from the gut
like they don't have the [__] space
age technology to make a set of
headphones
that that'll just last forever you know
can't do that can you
well if we make it last forever they're
never going to come back and buy another
one
then what are we going to do i don't
know go plant some beets you [__]
[__]
do you feel how [__] hot the sun is
lately have you felt it
you know do you remember it ever being
as [__] hot as it is now
like literally god has a magnifying
glass right up on the crown of your head
granted part of it could be because my
hair's thinning out
[Laughter]
but i choose not to address that this
week
you know the goddamn hole in the ozone
layer can you make [__] headphones
last a little bit longer
you know so now what i'm supposed to
throw out these other ones these flaky
ones that i can't even [__] find
right i love how you put it in the trash
put it in the [__] trash like like
it's still not going to end up outside
somewhere
it is outside we just have it over here
in this contained area
oh you know what i'm not going to be
able to tell whether any of this is
funny because i can't hear myself i'm
like a singer right now
you know turn up the monitors
oops i did it again
i shaved my [__] um
yeah so i gotta go out and go buy
another another [__] pair of
headphones
i'm one of those crabby old [__]
people who i when i buy something
i use it until it's [__] it it
becomes literally
a different matter you know what i mean
starts dissolving into a powder is that
a different matter all you eggheads out
there
well technically a powder is still a
solid it's just in a
more granulated form thank you never
[__] got your dick sucked
why don't you go back with your lab coat
and have a nice [__] hand job with
yourself
and uh pipe in aga again later when i
say something stupid
um i'm a little wound up this morning
i'm excited
an older wiser bill burr wiser than he
was last week i'm finally back
i'm back here in los angeles los angeles
you know which is always you know kind
of a creepy place to come back to once
you've been on the east coast
and you're sitting there looking at all
the green trees and all the ponds and
all the lush
land back there and i fly across the
[__] country as i always say watching
the country slowly die
right slowly getting [__] you know
geographical
chemotherapy um this usually a big
bandanna tied right over [__] arizona
in southern california oh that's good
built a little cancer joke in there with
your [__]
musings about our topography oh
topography
um but i got to admit i'm actually
excited
to be on this side of the country
i think i have a better chance of
surviving whatever the [__] is going to
happen to this planet
believe it or not in this overpopulated
city that technically has no water
supply
i have a better [__] chance why you
ask
i'll tell you why because i read a
[__] article
i didn't read it who's kidding who i
glazed over it
and it was so [__] depressing it
scared the [__] [__] out of me but as
far as i can tell
new york city is gonna look like venice
in about three years
that's what i'm guessing you know
it's going underwater that's what i
think
so if you're on the third floor or lower
you might want to consider selling your
apartment now
they're just doing all this [__] talking
about how you know the glaciers are
melting at a much quicker rate than
scientists first feared look at this
picture from july
now look at this one you know i have no
idea you know what's funny i have no
idea if the pictures
are even [__] real you know
they're like these uh these pictures
that show like you know
red and white white obviously being the
glacier red being
now like [__] the sunburned shoulders
of a redhead or some [__] right
so it's basically scaring the [__] out
of me and then i actually found comfort
in something
where they were saying that scientists
you know now that so much [__] has
melted
in antarctica they're actually saying
that um this is even being recorded i
can't even [__] hear myself
uh what's the solution bill should you
turn it up a little bit
maybe a little bit halfway through it
why not now look at it now it just went
through the [__] roof and i still
can't hear myself anyways scientists or
the writer who wrote the article maybe
they just made it up i have no [__]
idea
basically said that uh they discovered
you know that back in the day antarctica
was
antarctica bill antarctica antarctica
who gives a [__] you know
goddamn place with all those [__]
penguins sitting there pushing their
[__] eggs up who [__]
went saw that march of the penguins
why don't you just call it i want to cry
for the final half hour
you know that's what every nature show
is let's show you how [__] cute they
are
and now we're going to show you what
we're doing to them and now you sit
there with this hopeless sad [__]
feeling
right and then what if you'd like to
donate give the [__] and save the
penguins feet
right.com and then what do you do you go
over to your checkbook
you know and you pull out another check
and you write you write it out and then
you grab a [__] envelope and you grab
a stamp you do all that [__]
or you print out a stamp if you're using
stamps.com oh what a [__]
um right you mail it off thinking you
did a good thing
what did you do you just used a whole
bunch of paper
yeah you know right you do that enough
people do that they got to cut down
another trick right next thing you know
that little [__] penguin's got
nothing to sit underneath you know when
he jacks his little [__] penguin dick
to make another
egg is that how it works aren't they
like asexual
that they [__] jack off and with
their little flipper into the other
flipper
and then do like a pap smear [__] uh
sort of a george girvin
layup to their own [__] crotch area
[Laughter]
george girvin the iceman that actually
made sense
penguins ice right yeah go [__]
yourselves
anyways so um
this part isn't made up they actually
said that that the [__] antarctica
that that the [__] antarctica
okay for you people who are uh
scientists out there
jesus bill just say what they said just
say what the guy said that they
said that you now believe um he said uh
oh geez i can stop talking my cell phone
that antarctica
there's people punching their dashboard
right now spit it out
antarctica used to be a tropical forest
all right now i know a lot of rednecks
went well there you [__] go
[__] you know now i don't feel bad about
driving my [__] ford cowboy into the
[__] swamps running over a beaver
well i think their tails are so flat
they used to be round to me my truck
went in that crick
anyway ain't nothing i like than driving
over some hairy little [__]
i love it raccoons there's just
something about them raccoons
possums all of them they just got this
look on their face that just says shoot
me
you know i'm just going with my
instincts i'm out in nature and i'm just
going with it i'm seeing these little
[__]
they're staring at me i got my
headlights on them they just keep
[__] looking at you don't get shot
stop [__] looking at me that's how i
look at it
um this is what i believe
with that information that that guy said
that the other guys said that know what
they're talking about
so i i think that the global war i can't
believe i'm actually
trying to attempt to discuss this
subject i think global warming is
actually natural
but we are hastening it we're just
making it way [__] quicker we have it
on fast forward you know like you fast
forward through commercials
that's what we're doing and we're doing
that towards our uh
our own [__] demise which i think is
going to be tremendous you know
and then we'll die and then maybe all
the [__] that you know when they put a
microscope up to your skin
all that little [__] there that's
crawling all over you maybe maybe that's
the next thing
that's gonna build a skyscraper name it
after themselves
if people write a whole [__]
nice version of their life because
they're afraid that there actually is
some old man in this guy that's going to
[__] judge him when they die
you know if you could write your own
little thing your own little ditty about
your life
how would you sum yourself up i love
people that kind of know they were a
douche
you know although he didn't always right
there you know like okay
i know i'm kind of going to hell in a
way
speaking of which i started reading this
book
sins of the father it's a book i wanted
to read for a long time it was about joe
kennedy
and i figured what better time to start
reading that book
while i was taking an ultra white
vacation
on the island of nantucket considering
you get on the high-speed ferry
run over a couple of seals um
right out of hyannis port home of the
kennedy compound
you know and for so long what did they
say they call it camelot they're the
first [__] royally family and all
that [__] right
but i always heard you know that what's
his face joe kennedy was you know
goddamn rum runner
you know he made all this money insider
trading and all this [__] [__]
right so i want i want to read about i'm
gonna
i'm gonna see i wanna hear the other
side now that i've read the fluff
about all the sacrifices he made for
this country and all his kids dying you
know in war
and in public servants getting
assassinated and [__] going skiing
while trying to play football
right i was like i gotta check this [__]
out and i read it you know i got the
book i thought it was going to be a
great book
that book is
it's like a [__] i feel like some
soccer mom
reading some juicy like summer novel
like i should be digging my toes in the
sand with my knees up to my chest as i
read it it's just such a
one-sided and it's so so much [__]
hearsay
you know did he did he do this for this
reason or maybe he did it because he was
a
[__] first of all the guy made a [__]
load of money
all right let's get down to brass tacks
the guy is one of the weirdest looking
human beings i've ever seen in my life i
used to think all the kennedys had that
same look about them because they sort
of did a rothschild thing where they
kind of
they kind of [__] real close to the
farm so to speak
so they kind of had that and your uh
here comes my big [__] head over here
right
a [__] weird-looking dude i will
definitely give you that but when he did
his insider trading
it wasn't illegal you know
the guy actually says in the book that
it wasn't illegal so he didn't do
anything wrong
you know it was looked down upon it was
considered
a shady thing to do but the guy goes
and then he has some sort of quote of
joe kennedy go
come on let's do this quick before they
make a law against it it's like
where did you get that [__] quote
from i don't know so all i do is i'm
just skipping around the book
i want to see how he reacted when when
jack got whacked
i wanted to see what happened to that
kid that you know they said
was uh mentally challenged but maybe
wasn't was just a pain in the ass and
they gave her a [__] lobotomy
it's really just a sad [__] read i
just jumped around it and now i'm gonna
use it as a [__] paperweight and i
can't tell you how long i wanted to read
that book
i know what you're thinking right now
bill where the [__] are you going with
this i don't know
i don't know where i'm going i can't
[__] hear myself
all right for those of you who didn't
listen to my podcast last week
i have a new stand-up special called you
people are all the same
and it's airing exclusively it's
streaming whatever you could say
on netflix and i know what you're
thinking
is it only on netflix in america or the
united states
no sir ma'am transgendered person
it's uh hermaphrodites it's also on
canada netflix
it's also on ireland netflix
and great britain netflix which i'm
really excited about because i think i
got i think i have a very
a very uh user-friendly special got a
little choked up there
um i think people are gonna like it what
do you think about that
i'm actually i'm feeling good you guys
you guys wrote so many nice things to me
on twitter
which is a rarity to just get a whole
nice sea of niceness and i know a couple
of [__] right now just for the [__] are
they gonna write a bad one
but i know what you're up to um
so people asked me they said hey how can
i
regular guy regular old gal
just salt of the earth person how can i
get a hard copy version of that
hour of filth that you just put out on
netflix
um this is the deal um the hard copy
version the digital version whatever the
[__] you want to download it to your
ipod your [__] uh
ipad well i don't know whatever you
people use i don't i don't [__] know
anymore
okay however you want you want to go
[__] old school i'll put it on a vhs
you keep running your yaps
no i'm not doing that i'll put it on dvd
and all that stuff and you will be able
to get it
at my website and my website only
buildburr.com
that's it we got a whole page set up but
i just you know
it will be coming out in september gonna
let it marinate for a good six weeks let
people go oh i like it
where could i [__] buy it right and
then bam it's gonna be available
and uh the wonderful thing about this is
uh
i'm eliminating the middleman and that
way it can be [__]
cheaper you know i'm basically i'm doing
what radiohead did 10 years
ago i'm doing what prince did i'm gonna
do that thing you know and now it's gone
into the whole [__] comedy world
with uh louis ck aziz and all those guys
and i
being the hack that i am and i'm
following right in line
okay seems to be working for everybody
else why not me
um so there you go that's how you're
gonna be able to get it you're just
gonna go to my website
and uh as that day approaches when you
can do it
uh i will let you know and um
i don't know what the prices are gonna
be it seems like it's gonna be five
dollars
i wanna be i wanna have it be five
dollars in one cent
just to [__] piss people off you know
sacrifice some sales just for people but
this guy think he's one cent better than
everybody else
um so that's that's the answer to your
questions people have been asking me
um all right and that is it
back to the podcast if this podcast is
even being recorded god knows i can't
[__] hear myself
um speaking of stamps.com
everybody come on
don't do this to me oh i hate this
computer
i [__] what is the problem
what is the [__] problem i did it
right
oh what now you're gonna freeze up on me
you're gonna freeze up on when i need
you most
right right in the middle of the podcast
so now what do i have to do i have to
force [__] quit
i don't like force quit that's a little
too rapey isn't it in a computer sense
force quit there you go i'm forcing you
to quit yeah
like an overbearing father hey you know
one thing that i noticed about myself
besides you know the obvious that i'm an
extreme douchebag
is when i was down in uh nantucket i
really
had to work on not
hating rich people just because they
were rich
you know well let me get this stupid
commercial out of the way here real
quick not a stupid commercial
a very important information let me get
this to you here uh stamps.com everybody
uh are you sick of going to the post
office you know
do you not like going to the post office
are you busy do you got stuff to do
do you want to get caught up on your
favorite show but oh snap
i have to go to the post office wouldn't
it be great if you didn't have to go to
the post office yet you could get
everything that you could possibly want
at the post office
minus the attitudes right your own home
apartment
gazebo wherever you live well with
stance.com
it's easy to you to do all of that and
it's convenient you can buy and print
official us postage
using your own computer and printer get
exact postage for any letter
or package whenever you need it 24 7.
you can stand there naked with an
english muffin just printing out stamps
like a counterfeiter
if it was legal currency um then just
hand your mail to the mailman and you're
done
when i say you'll never have to go to
the post office again i really mean it
i use stamps.com that's how i send out
all my dvds
to all my shows i love it they give you
a little scale
you feel like you're in business you
feel successful you know
all they give you the scale i think they
should give you a little hat so right
now use my last name bur b-u-r-r
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus
offer that includes the digital scale
and up to fifty five dollars
in free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burr burr
that stamps dot com
enter burr i i endorse it i approve of
this message
so anyways i'm down in uh i'm down in
nantucket
and uh with all family friends extended
family and all that type of stuff
nieces nephews the whole nine yards
drinking again oh baby i'm drinking
again you know i'm down there boozing it
up
drinking some of that cisco brewery
whale tail pale ale whatever they got
down there
you know i got my little nantucket red
[__] um
i'm friends with the banker shorts on
i'm living the dream
all right and i'm just sitting there
walking around and i'm looking at all
these rich [__] people
and i just find myself i [__]
the level with which i was judging them
which of course no one would give a [__]
you know what i mean if i was judging
uh you know a a
a a a a what the [__] am i doing if i
was judging like you know some poor
group of people like that i would be
considered
the biggest douche ever all right you
don't know these poor people why
why are you judging them that way right
but you you
you why am i stuttering you [__]
judge rich people that way
everybody laughs they all think it's
funny you know
i had to work the whole week it's like
why do i hate that guy how do i know
he didn't get his money legitimately why
am i immediately assuming
that this guy was a complete piece of
[__] [__]
you know you know what it is i don't
like how rich people carry themselves
people born into wealth they just
have this like that time when i was in
dc and that little
[__] six-year-old kid got up went
walked right up to the bar got climbed
up on the stool
and started calling out to this adult
behind the bar
sir sir excuse me sir like
the co i can i'll never be able to do
the proper read of that
the way this kid said it there there was
such a comfort
in in in summoning this person over to
come and talk to him
to do whatever the [__] he needed him to
do at six years old um
it [__] annoys the [__] i mean i was
just looking at these these [__] rich
people
they have the creepiest looking goddamn
kids you ever seen in your life
just creepy little [__] future
bankers ceo looking kids
you know a little blonde hair they
already got those chubby [__] you
know all kids have chubby cheeks but
just the way they look
that waspy pedigree right
which is another thing i can get away
with you know what i mean
the waspy pedigree everybody will laugh
because gives a [__] about that you can
trash
waspi people up and down i can't be
other with this this this jewish kind of
blah blah that's it i gotta [__]
apology waspi
totally gets a [__] open lane
so anyways waspy [__] look about them
right with their [__] you know
oh they look like little winston
churchills
like they still talk like little kids
but they should be walking around here
we shall never surrender
they just look like they're gonna
[__] get they're gonna get some great
[__] job
and then they're gonna steal from the
company and when they get caught
they're not gonna get [__] prosecuted
just like these goddamn bankers
just like all these rich [__] they're
just not gonna because they're gonna
have connections
and people he's gonna know [__] about
people whatever and they just they just
hook each other up
the same way at the level that i grew up
you didn't rat out your friends they're
doing the same thing at their level
except what they can do
affects the entire population as opposed
to the level that i came up with where
you know
maybe somebody's car that used to be
there isn't there anymore
you know that's insurance fraud i guess
that hopes
that hurts the group after a while
doesn't it
i don't know so that was basically uh
what i had to work at you know and they
had this place down the street called
the summer house
i was staying out in scotland and uh
it's absolutely [__] beautiful and uh
i i just couldn't get myself to go in
there
i wanted to go in there i wanted to sit
down and have a [__] drink but every
time i saw
another person going in with their
[__] boat shoes
without any socks on like i felt like
this this hatred coming up
in me and i justified it for like two
three days and i was just like what the
[__] is wrong with me
you know i bet you know
those people that they're probably just
like me
or the people i hang out with in that
as i always say most of them are
douchebags but there's gonna be like
four or five people in there it can be
really interesting
i tell you time i flew on the plane
right i sat next to that guy
who made a ton of [__] money starting
his own credit card
and then he parlayed that money into
buying cell phone towers
the guy was [__] hilarious he had it
lost it had it all again lost it and
then now he was on top again he had this
hey what the [__] you gonna do vibe
self-made man so i'm thinking they're
going they're not all like that but they
all had that same
[__] uh their foot their [__] feet i
can't stand them
i really got issues because here i am
i'm down there i'm vacationing two
acting like oh oh but i'm the down to
earth douchebag with my salmon colored
shorts on
[__] hypocrite
i don't know so anyways i ended up going
out fishing
uh with my family we had a great time
didn't catch [__]
just caught blue fish didn't even catch
a striper
didn't catch anything but you know it
was still cool and we didn't take more
than
than we were gonna eat so uh i didn't
feel too bad about that but uh
i think i kind of got talked into doing
something really stupid the guy who had
the boat actually had a [__] shark
cage
and he's like you know it's totally safe
we take you about 15 miles out we chum
the water
and you get in this [__] cage and you
know what
ah after all these years of doing bits
about how [__] stupid it is to swim
in the ocean and all that type of [__]
i'm gonna do it
next year i'm gonna do it i almost said
it costs an arm and a leg
there's your [__] pun right there
you're awful joke but uh
it does it's really expensive but i want
to see a [__] shark
you know and i got that white thing in
me where i
uh that white person think where i want
to see
the shark being a shark you know
the same way i don't want to see a bear
just walking through the forest
i want to throw something at it so it
gets up on its hind leg
and starts doing that [__] like it's
about ready to step into the squared
circle right i think that that is
uniquely a white thing
that we we just we just want to see an
animal
looking like it's going to kill us or we
don't feel like
that we got the full experience
not okay now can i not only not hear
myself it's getting hot as [__] in here
and i don't even know why
oh bill probably because you know if the
windows open
um anyways what else do i have here
what else do i have here on the dock of
the [__] that i want to talk about
oh as you can tell i read rolling stone
here's another article i saw by the way
they have rick ross
on the on on the cover i don't know much
about the guy other than he's the most
confident
fat person i've ever seen in my life for
half a second i thought it was little
wayne
and he just went to like wendy's for 20
days in a row
how much does the tattoo artist not want
to tattoo
the underneath part of [__] rick
ross's man tits
you know because at some point you're
sitting there with your surgical gloves
and you got to hold it up and actually
feel the [__] weight of it as you
[__]
i wonder if he giggles um i actually i
started to read that article but i i
cannot
i can't read articles about rappers
at that [__] who come with that vibe of
look of all look at all this [__] that i
have
it's the most you feel like you're
reading like a a [__]
i don't know what jordan marsh catalog
that's all they i'm i'm st he said
something he was standing on
jewish marble is there such thing as
jewish marble i have no [__] idea is
it somehow
like uh she almost said kosher like some
[__]
porsche belt joke um at one point he
goes out to a [__] steakhouse
they list everything that he orders and
how much it costs
uh it's unreal if you it literally if
you honestly if you have
problems sleeping read that
and i'm not trashing the writer i just i
i
i'm on a [__] plane i'm trying to
kill time and i couldn't get through the
[__] article
oh do you smoke weed the whole time do
you have 50 000 [__] cars
i got it
you know what they call that nantucket
they call that new money
i never used to know what that
expression is he's new money
you know what old money does old money
acts like they don't have money
you know i mean they walk around in
salmon [__] colored pants
they call up their financial advisor and
then they manipulate the market and they
make more [__] money
and then all of a sudden they the
prohibition comes along and they gotta
hook up for scotch so what do they do
they [__] do it
i really don't have a prop well you know
something i didn't get into how he uh
i don't know who the [__] knows if
anything that they're saying about joe
kennedy is the truth
i want it to be the truth you know
because it makes you feel better about
yourself that's what it is that's why
you look at rich people like that you
have to look at them like they did
something [__] crooked
because if you don't it makes you feel
like a loser
his [__] yacht is bigger than all the
houses on my block
you know now if you give him the benefit
of doubt then you just have to stand
there and just take that [__]
or you can just say he's a crooked son
of a [__] he's going to hell
god loves me best right and you can walk
around with your [__] nose in the air
like you're better
huh with your slightly cheaper
salmon-colored [__] pants
i know what the [__] i'm talking about
so anyways so i'm nodding off reading
that whole [__] rick ross thing
you know
i don't know i'm sure he's got good
music i don't give a [__]
okay how many different ways can you say
i have more [__] than you do
you know like he was bragging about
eating lobster bisque
for breakfast that's what that's what
new money does
new money gets like [__] dvd
those dvd players in the head rest when
you're driving like a two-seater
remember that [__] i got those that's
for the people behind me
that's how much money i have i can
actually waste it
rather than taking that money and adding
to my portfolio
and and truly getting out of my [__]
up neighborhood
i'm gonna do that instead that's what
new money does straight across the board
straight across the board you get a
redneck a bunch of money you know what's
he gonna do
huh is he gonna buy some gold is he
gonna you know try to invest it is he
gonna start a business no
he's gonna put another three inches on
that truck he's gonna get some big
[__] motors
and hey he's gonna [__] drive down
the [__] street
he's gonna make his [__] engine
waterproof have that goddamn chimney
coming up the side of it so you can go
into the swamp and right back i never
have to [__] stop
that's my apocalypto [__] truck out
there
any [__] happens i'll drive over
everybody i'll just keep going till i
get up north pole make myself
[__] snow cone um that's what new
money does
right is that what they do i don't know
what they do you know what i do with my
money i just sit and stare at it
i don't know what to do with it the
money that i have i don't
i have no [__] idea what to do with
it
because you know what wherever you
invest it this is the funny thing about
investing your money
all of it involves you taking your money
and giving it to somebody else and going
all right
call you in a month it's the dumbest
[__] i ever did
you know in the [__] stock market
that's like getting in the mop once
you're in you can't get out
oh you can get out you know but it's
going to cost you
got to cut your [__] dick off
get your [__] [__] back out again all
right i think it's time for some more
advertising this is great
hey do you want to start your own
business do you want to make a will
you want to do all of that stuff enough
to pay a zillion dollars
well listen before i get going you've
probably already heard about
legalzoom.com but now
i am telling you about them so you got
to check them out because these guys are
great
all right this is a way this is
legalzoom and evoice
these these are my two things to get you
out of your cubicle
all right so pay attention copy points
if you've if you've been waiting for the
perfect time start your dream business
it's right now
you can incorporate your business or
form an llc at legalzoom.com starting at
just 99.
i paid 1500 you can do it for nine
dollars why do i need to incorporate
that way no one can sue you whenever you
did blows up in somebody's face
you actually pay less taxes it's what
smart people do
okay and i'm not smart so i can't
explain it beyond that
um and if you have a family uh guess
what
you need to make sure they're protected
i don't like that guess what
like i'm talking down to you and if you
have family i'm sure you already realize
you need to make sure that they need to
be protected and you can protect your
family and assets
with a legalzoom.com will for just 69
bucks
in the past 12 years over 2 million
americans have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks and
more they've saved hundreds even
thousands of dollars versus going to a
traditional lawyers i know what you're
thinking well i don't i need a
traditional lawyer to help me through
all that stuff don't worry they even
have attorney to help you through
um all the legal mumbo jungle jumbo
sorry
legalzoom uh online process guides you
step by steps
and you get total customer support it
couldn't be much easier
uh start your business and protect your
family at legalzoom.com
you also get a special discount from
listening to this podcast make sure you
enter bur
b-u-r-r in the referral box and check
at checkout for more savings legalzoom
is not a law firm and self-help services
are provided at your direction
in other words if you need help ask for
it okay
so good luck i want to see who the first
monday morning podcast listener is who's
going to use legalzoom
because they advertised here and now
you're out of your cubicle
wouldn't that be a great that would be a
great uh segment
you know people talking about how they
got inspired by this
filthy podcast and they somehow got
themselves out of that
[__] cubicle
um anyway sorry i know i'm drinking
water here uh all right
what else can i talk about here 34
[__] minutes in
you guys watching any preseason football
why not what are you watching baseball
and the six teams that are competitive
um oh speaking of which i was back in
boston
and uh i try really hard to listen to
that sports talk radio it's just [__]
it's impossible
who listens i actually feel bad for the
on-air personalities that they have to
sit there for four
[__] hours like like those legitimate
sports talk radio guys not the smart
ones who go all right
it's a sports talk radio show but we're
gonna talk we're gonna [__] about our
wives
uh we're gonna [__] talk about how we
went golfing and we
gambled and so and so sucked and i won
all that guy [__] and smoked cigars and
if something interesting is going on in
sports we'll bring it up
right like roger clemens gets acquitted
you know
by the way just because he got acquitted
he got acquitted uh
of uh lying under oath which is one of
the most difficult things to prove
okay so but if you think that that guy
didn't take a [__] something and
stick it you know where
and all of a sudden he's winning those
shiny things you're out of your [__]
mind see how he did that so i couldn't
get sued
that's just my opinion all right i
actually
have a number of people that i'm
watching as a sports fan
you know i'm telling you what's his face
melky cabrera i almost called paul verzi
and gave him [__] like ah you should
have got rid of this guy all of a sudden
he's coming on
that is the telltale [__] sign i
think now
of of of peds it's
it's what it's one of those it's
basically as simple as this because you
don't get [__] gigantic anymore
i think they got it down with that
little cream that will sove they have
like steroid lip balm
you know you just put it on your bottom
lip you go
and next thing next thing you know
you're [__] running over people
you're turning the corner and you're
hitting home runs
right just pay attention to people
who were okay and then they started to
taper off and all of a sudden they're
[__] great i'm telling you
that never happened when i was a kid
once you started tapering off you were
you were [__] done
i don't know maybe i'm sure there's
always a couple of examples oh by the
way one little [__] editor note last
week when i brought up the
um the spurs and the houston rockets i
talked so fast it sounded like i was
saying that those were pile on teams
i wasn't saying that so my i wasn't
saying that i realized
that you know you know that what's his
face elijah won they drafted and i
obviously real if i certainly realized
that tim duncan was from their system
because the celtics were in the lottery
that year and tim duncan would have been
you know he would have been great anyway
but he was such a perfect celtic you
know flutterbell basketball
boring as hell kissing the ball off the
glass jesus christ
[__] tommy heisen um
and david robinson i realized that those
were you guys so i was trying to say
that
those teams i respect they weren't pile
on teams but uh you know the nba
is uh it's over it's over
a bunch of little dream teams um
what the [__] was okay so i actually i'm
and i'm not going to say the person's
name
but it is a running back in the nfl
and his last name is the name of a beer
and it also talks about maybe a lady's
muff
um there you go there's just somebody
who i saw
was you know was the man in college was
not the man in nfl and all of a sudden
last year i'm watching him he's [__]
running over people
really you learned how to run over
people four years into it
i'm not buying it i'm not buying it
and the last hint as he plays on the
seattle seahawks that's just a
misdirection
um you'd have to be a two-year-old
enough to figure it out
um all right that's the deal
i want to start taking [__] royce
they're making them for us now i got a
whole new bid on it too so i can't burn
too much of this but it's about that
cinegenics
those [__] old roided up those guys
they're on they're on that's human
growth hormone that those guys are on
you know they show them all sad with
their man ticks tits
ticks man tits on their stomach and then
the stomach hanging on their [__]
giant
old man ball bag and then all of a
sudden like a month later
they look like an adonis you know
their ball bag looks like a [__]
speed bag again they're right there bang
their wife
is over in the corner right just [__]
squatting on a
tub of [__] ben gay because he just
tore it up like it was 1926 again
i want to know why those [__] people
aren't going to get brought before a
grand
jury for cheating you're going to bring
clemens out there
clemens in his big old butt right
you're going to bring him out there and
question all the 87 cy young awards he
won
past the age of 50. what about these
[__] old guys
all of a sudden with their old [__]
heads and their young bodies gonna go
down to the goddamn uh
[__] uh whatever the clam shack
right and just start banging out [__]
20 year olds
there's got to be a price that you're
going to pay for that is god going to
allow that there can't be a god
how is god allowing that
that goes against all the laws of nature
there's going to be
[__] 80 year old guys
with knocked up 25 year olds
yeah my girlfriend's pregnant right
they're going to be sitting there with
their [__] dentures and they're
righted up bodies trying to talk these
girls into getting abortions
you know and i'm telling that's what's
going to happen to this [__]
generation
all these guys these guys who invented
the [__] uh
youtubes the myspaces the facebooks all
of them by the time you know once they
figure this [__] out by the time they
get in their 80s they're all going to be
[__] roided up
they're going to be [__] knocking up
[__] 22 year olds
and then they're going to have them like
they'll somehow have them have to have
them
whacked can you imagine that would you
would you guys uh
i don't know would you do it
because they're gonna figure it out look
i'm 44.
i figured by the time i got to start
doing roids i figure right around 65.
so that's another 21 years if you go
back 21 years
what is it 2012 21 years that's 1991.
that doesn't seem that long ago to me
oh [__] i'm [__] you know what the
next guys you guys you guys in your 20s
by the time you guys get to
you know because if you go back another
20 years
that'd be 1971 and when you took roids
back then
like literally your balls they turned to
dust
you had like c-cup titties and uh
you know you turned into a [__]
werewolf
women did women turned into whereful
werewolf and guys became like these
[__]
psychos like women had like those merlin
olsen beards
and then guys just became these adonises
who look
like you know had like they had no balls
anymore
and they had tits
they they look like if uh
who's that guy in the [__] chicago
bears
like if mike ditka became like a
transgendered person that's what you
ended up [__] looking like and now
you know you can't even tell look at
milky cabrera that guy didn't look like
he was on anything
so i figured by the time the people in
their 20s you guys get there it's going
to be [__] over
like how good you guys are going to look
it's going to be another 60 years of
them practicing
facelifts all right to probably cure
baldness they're not even gonna know
you're probably gonna get carded at
[__] 68
and that's going to be like the new
thing with like chicks
like the new lie guys are gonna tell
they're gonna tell chicks that they're
i'm legitimately 28 years old and then
one day you're gonna forget to dye your
pubes and she's gonna see a couple of
[__] silver ones down there or
even worse white ones when she's down
there
grabbing your [__] prohibition error
[__] dick
she's gonna flip the [__] out
calling up crying mandy what's wrong i
found out he's 80.
that's okay he still has another 70
years left
right i remember reading one time this
guy that said these other guys said that
these scientists said
that the [__] uh that the body is
actually the body
my boston accent coming back bawdy
body is designed
to live 150 years you know that's how
that's how
difficult life is they had to have it
designed to live that long because the
way
nature beat the [__] out of you when you
lived in a cave you could only get
[__] 30 years out of it
you know oh by the [__] way
not by the way people this is by the
[__] way
which you know that i'm about ready to
tell you some [__] that i believe in
baby
uh i'm at i'm at logan airport
edward lawrence logan airport i finally
learned that logan airport is
as named after eddie lawrence logan who
was some sort of [__] uh
military person who fought in the
spanish-american war and that they used
to have a statue of him before they had
to make the airport even bigger because
people out [__] it you know
so i go there okay and i go through
security and they got the giant [__]
microwave they want me to stand in
with my legs spread doing the jay-z
symbol
right or the sami hagar from the
5150 tour depending on what generation
you are but
depending what what side of the track
you're from all right this podcast is
for everybody
um i'm sure someone in the village
people did it there
see that reached out to the gay
community swell guy
pat myself on the back here so anyways i
say i'm not [__]
you know i'm opting out all right sir
can you go stand over there
i don't even like standing over there i
used to work in a [__] dental office
when i would take an x-ray of somebody's
tooth
one little [__] thing and we put that
camera right up to the side of their jaw
we put a lead vest over all their vitals
right down to their dick or hoo-ha
and then i left the [__] room stood
behind a wall that had lead in it and i
pressed the [__] button
now i'm supposed to stand there
you know like i'm just going into prison
they do everything but you have you bend
over and spread your [__] ass cheeks
i'm like i'm not [__] doing it
and i know what people are saying well
bill you talk on his cell phone right
that's [__] radiation you're in an
airplane
right that's [__] radiation i
understand
that i am getting radiated throughout
the course of the day in the way i live
my life
i understand that okay but i don't need
to get
extra radiated so if there's a way to
opt out
believe me if there was a way to opt out
of flying on a [__] airplane
a a viable way aside from just saying
[__] this business i'm gonna buy an old
bus and just drive around
and that'll be my miserable life
i would do it but the fact that i can
just stand there for an extra five
ten fifteen [__] minutes you know
and rather than stand in that microwave
i could just go over and just have some
you know
sort of cute male person pat down my ass
with the back of his hands
do you have any sensitive areas um i
would much rather do that
okay and then you know people giving me
[__] about it saying it's stupid it's
[__] pointless and blah blah blah
well so anyway anyways i'm at eddie
lawrence logan airport edward lawrence
and um i'm standing there i'm waiting
you know and whenever you want to get
[__] patted down they wait for
[__] ever they'd make it take extra
long
i'm convinced that they do it just so
you just say [__] it i'm gonna go into
the toaster
all right but i don't give a [__] i
always get to the airport early
because i know the game that they're
running over there oh the lovely near
everybody
how are you i'm good come over here
talking to the microphone how you been
we couldn't hear you last week oh i've
been great thanks for asking
great to be back are you reading from a
script i am
no who just woke up i am great thank you
for harassing
yeah where's the real nia who is this
sexy robot that was replaced listen to
this [__] i'm telling this story about
you know i always opt out of doing the
jay-z thing where they radiate
everything but you [__] taint
at the airport jay-z yeah you know you
[__] you have your hands like the
hover sign
isn't that what it is yeah so um
i'm standing there waiting right and i'm
staring down some bald-headed douche who
knows
first of all they always have some chick
there and she just goes you know
what are they what are they what do they
say uh mail
ah what is what they say male pat down
or whatever they say yeah yeah
male support aisle five whatever the
[__] they say
and it's typical chick voice where it it
ca it can only carry
what is that you guys aren't good at
yelling yes we are
like no one hears it no one hears it all
right go ahead
you know i got the microphone away yell
mail support aisle four
yell it i want to hear it i want to hear
what song
that's good that has a sense of [__]
urgency
all right then you know what they don't
put their [__] heart in it they just
got a male packed out although they say
because
he's screaming like there's something
going down or whatever yeah but you
gotta communicate
you gotta communicate to those bald
fatties guys down there gonna put the
back of their hands on my ass
there well they they don't they don't
get it they have a whole little system
that they're talking to each other that
you you whose [__] side do you want
here
not yours obviously all right well
listen to this [__] listen to this [__]
wait a second let me let me get to the
point
hey go get time out time out get another
microphone
get another microphone hang on a second
we're actually going to pause the
podcast
part the podcast all right so the magic
of hitting pause that's something i
never do on this thing actually hit
pause there uh so anyways this is the
deal so i'm going through security yeah
after all these people ridiculed me like
oh you're already getting radiation
anyways man
so why not stand there and have
literally have your entire body but your
taint
lit up right so i'm [__] standing
there and
this lady is going hey [__] yeah mail
support out for
you know and i'm like they're not
hearing you they're not here and then
she goes sir could you stand
over there i go i'm gonna stand right i
need to watch my wallet okay you can
stand right there
all right so anyways this [__]
this asian kid comes up fat asian kid
one of the rare ones
why why like like like like like a white
elephant why
is that relevant because asian people
are in great shape they eat great i
don't know what it is they're in [__]
awesome shape
and every once in a while you see one
you see a fat age you're like holy [__]
right i don't mean like he's a [__]
did it on purpose to sumu wrestle this
is just a fact
sumo sumo samoa whatever the [__] it is
this fat asian kid comes up
not relevant to the story for the comedy
it is
no i see all right sorry come on listen
i trashed
waspy [__] white people on this oh
you did you talk about nantucket yes i
did
oh boy ahoy yeah see you just hate him
and it's right i don't hate anybody i
don't have hate in my heart
all right shut up listen so this this
this
this person this fat kid comes up
all right and the ladies and the ladies
goes
hi he couldn't even hear her he goes
he's like what
say hey he's like what and i want to be
like how old are you that's what the
[__] she's trying to say
and he goes 13 and she goes
all right come over here and she had him
go through the old school one
yeah so basically
you want me to stand in something that
could kill a 13 year old
that's what the [__] i'm supposed to do
you know on the wait wait on the way out
on the way back
twice two times two times that four
times a month i'm gonna stand in this
thing
that can kill a 13 year old it can't i'm
sure it can't kill it maybe it like can
affect his like um
puberty or his growth or something i
think
women can affect his dick i have a dick
too what because my dick's old now yeah
no one cares about it anymore like it's
just kind of like
out of commission i think women can
avoid that
full body thing by saying that they're
pregnant and they won't let you go they
won't make you go in there if you say
that you're pregnant exactly
you can always you women always have the
i'm just a girl excuse
me to get out of this horrific things
that guys have to do
but stick with the thing here if that
[__] thing
how old are you 13. get over here
get him from getting like chest hair or
something but you yeah you're old like
they don't care about you it's the youth
of tomorrow that we're concerned about
well there you go i sat there and i uh
this isn't about me whether i i feel
like i'm old or not i know i'm old
i'm talking about it's very bad um
i almost high-fived myself i actually i
bursted out laughing extra laughed
because i wanted [__] merry mumbles
to be like
marry mama yeah what are you laughing at
i'm laughing because i'm doing the right
thing
if that [__] thing isn't safe for a
goddamn 13 i could see if it was a bit
making some little baby crawl through
there he's a [__] kid
who probably knows more about computers
than i do and they're like yeah no
don't think so come over here all right
nia you know what it's time for
it's time for some questions
then we can wrap this up oh first of all
g bill
i enjoyed your stand-up special on
netflix canada so much
are you coming up there actually i'm not
i still have dates in the states why
don't you ever go to canada oh no you've
gone to montreal a couple times why
don't i go to canada
yeah because i didn't like the way they
were portrayed in all those michael
moore movies
like they are just so goddamn perfect up
there despite the fact that they can't
even handle losing a [__] hockey game
oh that's turning down every starbucks
yeah that was a kind of uh
is that something that canadians do
often though is that a normal thing
in canada for the the riots to happen i
would never pretend to think that i know
what a canadian person is thinking
oh you wouldn't i wouldn't okay that's
an arrogant thing to do
and you want to be ashamed of yourself
and you i apologize i love canada i've
only been to montreal i've only been in
montreal i've been there twice
it was amazing it was lovely the people
were awesome
that's like i went to england i only
went to london and they'd be like oh i
love
england all right well then get out
there muck it up
get out there in the sticks those people
who are too dumb to live in london
i'd like to go to toronto sit next to
one of them with some fish and chips
hanging out of his mouth and you tell me
how much you like it
you get to the ugly seedier side the
seedy underbelly the seedy underbelly
like we're going to australia coming up
we're going to be going in
sydney the shiniest of all shiny cities
over there that's how you're going to
judge us oh we're going to sydney
yeah rather than going out to the
[__] outback with all those toothless
people playing that long horn that
doesn't sound good
right didgeridoo did you read too all
right i'm going to be in orlando
home of disney world september 7th 8th
and 9th
then i'm going to be in charlotte
the comedy zone september 13th 14th and
15th so these are all the comedy clubs
what what date was that again for
charlotte 13th 14th
and 15th of september oh okay great
uh got some people that want to go to
them cool and then
uh i'll be at caroline's in new york
city the the
one i had to make up that's right i had
to reschedule that because i had that i
booked the pilot of the news the reboot
of zoom
that's right
that's uh caroline's is september 20 21
22 and i believe 23. it's it's a
thursday through sunday there's only
three
oh you're going to be gone a lot awesome
yeah we've had enough features but we've
had enough of you we've spent a lot of
time
a lot of time a lot of time like that
when you go on a lot of times
a lot of time it's been great it's been
good bye nene bye
yeah see ya all right
uh funeral music uh i i was saying i'm
you know
relative passed away yeah how she picked
out her her
her uh outro music planned out no it was
great the best funerals ever
rather than just being sad it was like
oh you got to feel more of a personality
yeah it was awesome
um anyways hey bill funeral music sure
you can have some ac dc
hey it's your funeral right um i did the
music for my dad's funeral
three years ago weird huh i was 25 at
the time
dude you manned up yeah you did you
manned up because that's what happens
when
the older generation dies is the younger
one has to step up
there's there's always a person who
steps up and then there's people who
just can't deal and there's the selfish
people like
i can't i have a rock throwing festival
i'm going to
you handle the pain um proctoring
um anyways he came into black betty
oh
that's awesome right there you feel like
you're at a concert yeah
also played uh
uh he says pronounce gaudete
i don't know what to say and a couple
more it's spelled g-a-u-d-e-t-e i'm sure
i've heard it
no i don't know what that that that that
that that that that that that that that
that that that that date i don't know
what that is and a couple more rock ones
that i can't remember
and no religious [__] in between that's
[__]
that's great that's how i'm going out
yeah you know what i'm gonna go to that
damn uh what the hell was it that i just
told you to go to
legalzoom.com write up my own damn will
and that's gonna be part of it
you're gonna whoa black belly bamboo
lamb whoa
um one more thing i gotta i gotta read
here uh e-voice
and then we're done i think with the
advertising except for two quickies in
the end e-voice
oh hey if you this is another it's a
great way to start a business where you
know you still you know you don't have
an office but you want to make it sound
like you do
you don't have money for 58 cell phones
but you could have you know a bunch of
different cell phones
oh yes you were showing me the website
today yeah this is actually looks very
cool
i keep saying viral phone numbers it's
not that not viral it's not viral what
is what is the proper kid terminology
tell me what do you have the proper
terminology for what now
for phone numbers you're in the air man
but they're not there and they go into
your phone
man i don't know what it is virtual
virtual phone numbers you can literally
have like
[__] 15 phone numbers they all ring
to your phone
they got these professional uh voice uh
actors that will act like they're your
your sexy you know double 06
vixen of a secretary oh six whatever the
hell is he's double 07. he's on top
oh i see right you get it um e-voice
your mobile phone at work
one of the great e-voice features is
music on hold make your business
seem more professional as e-voice will
treat your clients and customers to
music on hold
hey you sound like you're calling some
giant building as you're sitting there
sneaking around in your computer
and your cubicle right you go to legal
zoom you get yourself incorporated
you're on your way out
yeah it's like the great escape you dig
in the tunnel it's tremendous
um you can even set up e-voice to run
promotional advertisement for your
company
while people are are on hold instead of
music yeah that's good
like coming up at joe blows frisbee fest
you can
i have your toes painted sorry evoice
also has
call recording features which is perfect
for doctors lawyers real estate agents
hiring managers and any other
professional
discussing uh contracts um easy to use
you just press star two to start and tar
start to
to stop it's easier than me reading this
copy perfect if you're driving
and can't write something important down
e-voice makes your life easier and seem
more professional
for free for a free six-month trial
for six months that's pretty good do it
yeah they have to get on it you can do
like uh
conference calling you can have up to 90
people on hold for when you have your
massive
drug dealing uh international thing
there
people ideas oh please nia this this
whole thing is set up
you can use this for good or evil just
like the internet yeah you can learn
about turtles
or watch something you shouldn't have
seen you know this is the same thing
with e-voice
they're giving you the option to start
your business
and get out of get out of your cubicle
and start living your dream
or you can use it for evil you know
i don't think that's perfect and start a
whole another family or whatever
you want to do and you got six months to
do it with a free six-month trial go to
www.evoice.com or go to the banner on my
podcast page at billbird.com and uh
get out from under it everybody yeah you
know what that's that's good even for
so that way is this the thing where you
can give somebody
your actual no it's it's not yours
you give them your number and they don't
have your real number oh but they don't
have your real
you don't have your real numbers but it
brings to your phone and you have the
option of turning it on turn it off it's
like it's some star trek stuff
and it gets you out of com cubicles so
you can avoid
situations like this look at this right
back to the podcast that right there
segway very nice um office rumor and
marry
uh hey bill uh great show and all that
bs
anyways i came in to the office where i
work on friday
my boss came up to me very angrily and
said
you up to something staring in his face
see he voiced legal zoom you get out
from under this
he goes i didn't know what the hell he i
don't know what i didn't know what the
hell he meant so i said
no he said he'd been watching me
that's what he basically you walk in on
a friday you psyched for your weekend
this guy comes up and goes you up to
something
you say no and he's like i'm watching
you and walks away
you just have to sit there and take it
right slink back into your
goddamn cubicle he goes i found out
later that everyone in the office thinks
i [__] the secretary mary
i didn't because i didn't i asked
i asked mary about it and she said that
she made it up
don't guys usually do that he goes i
thought it was sexy
oh geez oh jesus jumping right into this
and then they really [__]
yeah i had always admired mary from afar
and thought she was a good match for me
i really want to date her but i feel you
want to date this girl just put her on
the desk and bang her you're already
getting [__] over for it you might as
well
this isn't the mother your kids dude
this chick is a psycho will you
stop it already what you are such an
[__] when it comes to wait let me
finish reading let me sexual or
asserting her sexuality and you're such
a
[__] hypocrite about it because you
love that [__]
okay so don't sit there on like some
sort of moral high horrors
this is the mother of your children this
is how women should act
madonna and [__] like you know what i'm
saying
are you done yeah just say [__] please
[__] please there we go all right
coming soon to a podcast
that's right when are you gonna start
the [__] please podcast i'm gonna start
i got a lot of [__] going on
yes coming soon the [__] please podcast
yeah my own
my own podcast yes and you should you
should now that i've said the name you
should definitely go out and start the
website or anything
anyways he goes he goes i really want to
date her but i fear that if i do my boss
will fire me
or otherwise hurt my career because he
is strongly against
office relationships what should i do
yeah all right first of all right there
that's why you need to get out from
underneath this dick
because he's literally saying who can
[__] who this guy's on a total power
trip
no that's that's a normal policy in
workplaces they frown on
interpersonal relations you're up to
something i'm watching you
that's a tough yeah that's like i'll go
to hr and talk you know what he should
have done
he should have kicked him in the balls
from behind when he walked away
get that nice sound yeah that nice sound
of a foot hitting this
the the mc hammer part of the slacks all
right so mary no
wait you just tore me a new [__]
[__] this is what i'm talking about
nia
what that chick is [__] in the head
why she made she made a joke of
inappropriate joke that got around
absolutely concerning yourself sexually
is that she just comes up to him
and asks him out or whatever i don't
have a [__] problem with that yeah
to walk around you know what you want to
talk about [__] hypocrite
you're a [__] hypocrite why because
if he sat there and he said that he
[__] somebody
he didn't [__] in the office how would
you look at that
uh exactly okay this chick is doing she
has some sort of
she has some sort of this chick is a
[__] psycho you don't have to go that
far to be like they're a psycho but i
you did you do make it it's a major red
flag it's a decent point because you
have a man set
talking down to me it's a decent point
stop pat me on the [__] head
it's a great goddamn head and i gave you
a [__] example and you
you actually shut you up for half a
second which is not an easy thing to do
i am saying that it was a good point put
your eyebrows down
all right now you i see what you did
that's classic female [__] there
see what you did you're blaming me for
your behavior
why because this is what happened for
your classic overreaction
and like you know because you assumed
that me saying
that this chick is a [__] psycho yeah
you immediately assumed that i was i was
saying that women can
uh assert themselves sexually okay and
then i turned it around and i gave you
an example you better point
you better put it away all right i'll do
the bill clinton fist i did not have sex
improper relations um because bill no no
no half your act is about
let me finish all right then i gave you
the example what if some guy said he
[__] you
and he didn't [__] you what would you
think about that guy oh he's just
asserting himself sexually
is he hot what's the stop stop stop
going with the joke
all right all right all right yes i get
your point i get your point yes
no that's not good enough what do you
want me to say
because you're going i get your point
that's a decent point you pat me on the
[__] head i made a great goddamn coin
point after you sat there and you
flipped out of me calling me a hypocrite
and all this [__] you won your
little [__] please [__] rant
and i came back now you actually
understand where i'm coming from because
you [__]
leaped off the guy you just took a
little thing and you ran with it because
you watched me tell some jokes for
[__] 10 years
um i mean you're right
you're right i am right it would not be
and it's killing you
be okay yeah you do that fellas that's
how you do it you don't let them worm on
their way out of it that's what she did
she tried like three different
techniques of patting me on the head
it's a decent point
and then you did the other thing when
you knew that i was right then you put
your eyebrows up like
yes you're right like i'm being an
overbearing [__] because i can't
be an overbearing [__] in order to
win one of these things because i said
whoa i said it was a good point so i
don't know what more you want from me
but yeah do you remember do you don't
remember your new rockne speech you gave
[__] 90 seconds ago about an [__]
i was
screaming and yelling and all that and
then when you find out i'm right you go
okay that's a decent point you don't
think that that's
you know yeah i think it's me giving
that'd be like if i took my bare foot
right now and i just
pushed you right in the face with it and
then you went over the side of the bed
hit your head started to cry and you
said that i was wrong and i said all
right you're right maybe i pushed you
too hard
then all all of this is besides the
point the point is he actually likes
this woman
no no no no no no no no no see once
again the last second she tried to warm
her way out did you see that not warming
anything i'm just trying to get back to
the it's not beside the point
it isn't beside the point you just read
me the riot act and you were [__]
wrong
i don't know that i was completely wrong
i don't know why aren't you making eye
contact anymore
i don't think that i was completely
wrong i just think that you brought up
a good point that i hadn't considered
you judged me that i hadn't considered
of course what else do i have to judge
you on of course i judge you
i'm not saying that's wrong yeah my
entire life is judging people on past
behavior
okay but when you find out you're wrong
you just say yeah you know what i was
wrong which i do and you never give me
[__] credit for what
when when do you ever say i was wrong
whenever you do something wrong
no you come in and you snuggle up beside
me and you make a little joke or you
like try it again i say i'm wrong and
i'm going to work on it no
that's not what happens at all you try
to cue your way out of it
and like charm and do a little funny
dance and hey everybody i'm billy
okay you know your face you know what
and that's how you get out of it
all right some of the times i do that i
do admit that when i'm seriously [__]
wrong
when i'm when you're seriously wrong you
do apologize that's true and i say oh
we'll work on it right well there you go
jesus christ it's like public [__]
teeth all right female question about
anal
there's a nice segway oh my wait did we
even give that guy advice though or do
we just go off on our own
relationship here's the advice
uh don't date this girl
if you're gonna bang her i mean you're
rolling the dice because then she's
gonna be like okay
last week it was a joke but now i really
am oh that's true she might blow up your
spot because she's already talking out
of school
yeah that's a good point this and this
guy has the problem
that i have is that when he meets a
[__] looney bird
who's [__] all about it you just
[__] you can't you can't
you know you just yeah that's like a
that's literally uh that's like a second
degree like dick
black belt to be able to walk away from
free [__] like that and i i'm sorry
that i'm being crass
i'm just i'm running out of time here
i'm just trying to get to the point here
follow up was a virgin not a virgin
anymore this is before the female
question about anal
i wrote a okay this guy got [__] laid
hey
you broke your cherry i wrote in a few
months back elaborating on my situation
wait a minute
i remember this 20 i got a lot of
virgins calling in
writing it as a 21 year old virgin
uh oh i was gonna make a really bad joke
there a lot i got a lot of virgins
typing in on uh semen stained keyboards
i know it was gross i think it's funny
to me
in my head all right sorry i wrote it a
few months ago i
i helped this person a few months back
elaborating on my situation as a 21 year
old virgin
conservative girlfriend where the
furthest we went was oral sex
as well as subsequent hookups with other
girls only stopping there
um so you're kind of getting blown i
don't really consider that a virgin i
just can't see you like
i was gonna say you're kind of having
you're like you're like a dh
you like the dh you're not out in the
field you know
you just come you but you go to bed
every couple innings
i don't know though but is a guy still
over like not a virgin if he gets blown
but a girl is
it's still a virgin if she just gets if
a guy just goes down on her because then
her
hymen isn't broken no no no as a guy
you're still a virgin until you you
banged a girl right it's kind of you
gotta go in there yeah and a woman
you're still a virgin slash you're kind
of hoary
if the other way around i don't have
time to get involved in the debate
anyways
um as well as subsequent hookups are the
governor this
was when i asked you whether telling a
girl that i was still a virgin before
slash during during during coitus
i don't know what that means fornicating
was a good idea during
does this jolt your memory absolutely it
does i actually lost my virginity
30 minutes before my actual birthday
with the girl
i'm currently dating there you go there
you go
good for you so yeah it's not like i was
a [__] [__] or anything
uh you were right about telling a girl
about my sexual experience or lack
thereof
she was actually totally fine with it of
course see i'm not a bad guy i gave this
guy some advice
it worked and was surprised that i was a
virgin
which i guess i should take as a
compliment absolutely
it means you're probably kissing her
nice rubbing at titties the way she
liked it over there
um anyways i'd like to thank you for
that as a small part
uh it may uh as small of a part as it
may have been it still helps well there
you go so what is
very good now if i could follow this up
with another short question oh jesus
me and this girl been hooking up pretty
frequently now he's gonna have some dirt
question here all right here we go
now he's gonna get technical now i'm
just [__] going
how do i improve on that um is that
disgusting
um and the one issue i have is that i
used
i have to use a rubber you did say safe
sex
is like boxing keep yourself protected
at all times
uh unfortunately when i do put one on i
can't feel
[__] and therefore tend to lose my erect
erection after a while
and it's not like she isn't hot or
anything uh
cute asian that's number two with the
asians
one fat asian one cute one
now number one what is wrong with saying
she's a cute asian
nothing she's a hot black chick how dare
you
say that she's good looking and describe
her thank you
there you go um stop talking different
condoms
number one have you ever encountered
issues like this yes
and how would you go about solving it uh
is it actually my fault no because what
you know what it is dude
you're used to [__] mouth on dick
contact and now all of a sudden you're
putting the dick up your
your condom on and it feels like you're
you're in the abyss
this is what you're gonna get used to it
jerk off with the condom on this stuff
that you could do
don't jerk off for a while you have to
get used to the sensation again it sucks
but i'm telling you he could get those
thin ones though
the real thin lamb skin or whatever yeah
i could run through that x-ray machine
at the [__] airport too
no i'm telling you this is the greatest
thing you can do now that you're [__]
but i'm going to give this kid some
advice try to get some different kind of
con
like experiment with different condoms
no no trojans are super
thick no there's other ones that are oh
this is what you want to do
okay okay in this day and age
with greenland [__] melting and the
water rising in new york okay
you you cannot you have to wear you got
to [__] go all out
no i'm saying he should wear a condom
yeah don't get the one that does the
[__]
thin one this thing too you can wear a
condom still get herpes i still don't
understand how that happens
is it on your ball bag or if you shaved
your nuts that day and then you [__]
against it i have no idea it's a risk of
getting something that's just
what goes down so this is the thing dude
uh right out of the gate
get used to [__] wearing condoms i
can't even [__] tell you
how psyched you're gonna be you know if
this doesn't work out you have a
one-night stand as much as it sucks
then there's there's no [__] better
feeling the end
when you walk out knowing that you wore
one you know it's what you always do
after you have sex
you go okay you know yeah oh i got to go
throw this thing out right and then you
go and you put your dick in her sink and
[__] and you scrub that [__]
and then you walk out you put you use
her face towel oh my god get the [__]
out of there stop
or do you know what else he could do and
you know [__] horse which is hard
you know what else he could do if he's
in a relationship with this girl he's a
virgin
i don't know what her sexual history is
they could both go to the clinic
together
get tested for everything everything
across the board
just do that and then still wear a
condom because you have no idea what the
other person is going to do
you could be with the sociopath you
don't have time for this yeah don't [__]
that
[__] all of that but if they're in like
a committed thing
you know the 21 near the 21 she's gonna
run into one of these write it up 80
year old guys that has [__]
70 70 years of game and he's gonna
[__] talk her into going down on his
[__] gross
babe ruth dick uh female question about
anal
this is the last one i got a kid i got
to get out of here
um my husband keeps jokingly bringing up
the subject of anal sex
it'd be funny if i [__] you in the ass
you have him call write me in and ask
how we should go about asking you for
anal
oh there's no there's no asking with
anal you just do it
wow no i'm kidding wow now what it is
you have to you have to do a survey
during during doggy style
that's what that's how you figure it out
it's done with the thumb
it's sort of rubbing circular motion
williams
[Laughter]
what is wrong with you just finish
reading it
just finish reading it okay to stop and
just read
please for the love of god oh this guy
just
joking around i i love these pancakes
almost like i'd love to [__] you in the
ass just kidding
just cuz it's kidding sweetheart
oh this poor guy he wants to [__] you in
the ass he doesn't know how to bring it
up after cornflakes this is the funniest
thing ever
in the past he always acted as though he
thinks it's gross
maybe he didn't he's just watched so
much porn that he's now graduated to it
which is the danger my sister told me
that a few of her girlfriends said they
actually enjoy it oh that means your
sister likes it
you know i have this friend yeah she
loves it he says
that it enhances um he's very well
endowed
and i weigh only all of 95 pounds yeah
it ain't happening
it ain't happening i think my concern is
well founded yes it is
but wait a minute those porno girls can
take it you can take it too come on be a
trooper uh what is your opinion about it
should i let him
what would nia say you just heard what
he what she has to say
he he listens he listens to this say no
please you want female listeners punk
help me out thanks [__] yourself uh
if you really don't want to do it then
you should do it
you know there's no reason it'd be one
thing if you didn't have a viable option
somewhere else yeah that was actually
you know what i mean it's basically you
have a nike's
you have a nice probably mid-sized
uh sedan going on there and this guy for
some reason
despite his size is going with the mini
cooper
look they do i got to be honest
workshops it's not something you don't
want you don't want to do that with your
wife
you just don't okay i thought that's the
one person you would want to do
no not if i
dingbat that says she's already banging
you at work okay that's who you do it
too right on the desk
you [__] in the ass mush your face
into the card catalog
and then you know what the card catalog
whatever the [__] they got nowadays
that that's how you do it with that's it
okay that's the podcast for this week
um oh i got one real quick one for well
if i'm a lady
um yeah so i i don't know
i don't know what to tell you it's like
you know you're 95 pounds he has a giant
dick
what are you going to do there i have no
idea you know what i would do i would
call in dr drew's show
and have them uh i would i'm going to
pass you through yeah
send that one up the up the ranks they
uh you know what
we don't have to i don't know no no
really quickly if you i don't know what
city you live in
but if there's a sex shop near you they
normally have
like these anal sex workshops like
taught by women or whatever and a couple
can go in
you pay a little bit of money and they
should like they talk you
like they tell you how to do it so that
it's gentle and it's not freaking
out
when you go into a sex store and they're
[__] in there but how did you get
there where are the anal sex shop like
open mics
like where do you start like you're
sitting in a cubicle and like you know
what i think i would make my million in
new york city people
yeah how to take their big dicks into
new york city there was a place called
toys and babe land and they gave all
kinds of workshops how to get [__]
how do you become that [__] person i
don't know that's what i'm saying
where are the open mics i don't know
that's a good gig you want to sit there
talking about him you're acting like a
bunch of hotties like
a writer you work in a sex shop you
learn about things and then you just
become an expert you study it or
whatever you talk to people yeah i know
you don't even know what you're talking
about you literally were looking up at
the ceiling sort of shaking
pulling ideas out of the sky probably
just you know you just you have a
parachute and you land on the store and
they say hey you want to talk about
dicks
humble female breadwinner hi bill um i'm
one of those
ladies who usually takes too long to
tell a story so i tried really hard to
make this quick
this is actually shorter than most of
the guys so i appreciate it uh i make
three times more money than my boyfriend
of 15
of one and a half years sorry 1.5 years
jesus christ how career driven is her
1.5 years
look at me i'm already insecure that
she's making more money um i have zero
problem with this because money is not a
big issue with me
it's a tough economy and he's very hard
working lately this seems to be more of
an issue for him course it is
he makes a bigger deal about going out
to eat and took a weekend job so we
could
see each other less
he has told me that he is ring shopping
and even though
i have told him many times that i don't
want anything fancy or expensive
he counters saying when i show my
friends i'll be embarrassed and he wants
to give him something really nice yeah
any advice on how to convince him i'm
not a material girl now what you got to
do is support the guy because
there's you got to understand that as a
guy like
going out and earning a living that's
that's what we're there for and when
we're not doing it not only we can't do
it at that time because we don't have a
job
and you're [__] doing it no matter
how cool you are it's totally [__]
emasculating
it'd be like if i could all of a sudden
have a [__] kid and you couldn't get
pregnant
and i was over there [__] nursing a
baby as creepy as that
that's a bad example i'm just saying you
know what i mean
men want to be the provider that's like
in their nature
so no that's our job
it's our job it's our [__] job it's
the same way
that women like when you're with a woman
if you get into good
shape they get [__] insecure like
they don't like a lot of women as much
as they like those shredded guys they
don't want to be with the guy that's in
that good of [__] shape because then
they're like [__]
now i have to be in that good shape and
i can't go to those cheese fondue lava
[__] things
you know and stick my tongue in it with
a glass of wine
and pontificate about sex in the city or
whatever the [__] it is you brought to
listen you wanna oh my god you wanna
like uh
those are absolutely disgusting by the
way that cheese comes
you guys sit there sticking the cheese
yeah it's gross it smells awful
terrific yeah i don't i don't like
fondue you don't like fondue
no it's weird all right i went to a
fondue restaurant it smelled like feet
i would just say listen you got to
support this guy just say to the guy
just say listen
i get it i get it this you don't have a
job right now and it's [__] hard for
you
and uh i have a hundred percent faith
that yet you're gonna find another job
we're gonna have a great life and you
know
you don't have to buy a ring right now
but when you get your job and everything
you want to go out buy me a
i totally respect the fact that you're
thinking about me being embarrassed
about my friends just support the guy
and he'll be fine yeah that's all you
got to do just support the guy
because right now no matter unless he
hears that from you
he's just going to automatically think
that you're thinking that
you know he's not a provider and he's
not a good guy he needs to hear it from
you
the same way that when you lady
maybe put on a few you got to tell her
she's still looking good
right why are you looking at me like
that
because lately you've been slipping
that's the podcast
oh my god no i was actually thinking
like i'm giving a good advice
maybe she'll please she'll pleasure me
later um
i just left it at the good advice you
know
you could have not asked the question
you could have not shown up
come down here you know i didn't ask you
on the podcast yes you did
yes yeah i did i asked you last time i
said you hadn't been here in a while we
missed you
we missed you here in the podcast all
right last two things amazon.com would
you like to support
the troops and this podcast next time
you're going to go to amazon.com to buy
some silly straw
go to buildburr.com first click on the
podcast page click on the amazon.com
link
it'll take you right there you don't
have to do anything else once you get
there go buy something buy an old
baseball card
uh amazon will give me some money i
kicked 10 percent of it
actually kind of been kicking 10 of all
advertising to the uh
wounded warriors project it's a great
thing it was what should be done
you know what i mean it's what should be
done so there you go and gamefly.com
hey do you want to sit on the couch
smoke some weed and uh eat some
cheez-its
well going into a different world
um anyways gameflight.com is awesome if
you're into video games they got 8 000
games for you to choose from
you got a two-week free trial you get
them direct to your pc or delivered
right to your damn apartment gazebo
tent city wherever the hell you live you
can play all these games uh 8 000 games
for a two week trial take two weeks
vacation and sit there
and play 8 000 different games
right gamefly.com
go to the go to gamefly.com burr no
gamefly.com yeah
or the banner ad on my podcast page for
the free trial enjoy all the video games
you can play
that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [__] yourselves hey thanks for
all the
nice compliments about uh my guest star
on
breaking bad and uh all the wonderful
things you guys said about my special
you know really means a lot to me i
appreciate it all right thank you
you